بام بام تي
[موسيقى]
في يا غنماتي ما ما ما احلاك ما ما ما
اطعمكم ما ما ما اسقي ما ما عشبا اعطيكم
وغذاء ان شئتم اسقي ماء ماء ما ما ما ما
ما ما
ما ما ما يوميا اخذكم رحله نقضي معا
اوقاتا احلى يوميا اخذكم رحله نقضي معا
اوقاتا احلى نجري نلعب ماء ما حتى نتعب
ماء ماء نجري نلعب ماء حتى
نتعب نجري نلعب حتى نتعب ونعود د الى
المرعى ماء ماء ماء ماء ماء ماء ماء ماء
ماء ماء ماء ما ما ما ما ما ما بطريق
العوده نترا فق في فرح نجري نتسابق بطريق
العوده نترا فق في فرح نجري نتسابق نقفز
نله ماء ماء صوتنا يعلو ماء ما نقفز نلهو
ماء ما صوتنا يعلو ماء ماء نقفز نلهو
صوتنا يعلو ونعود الى المرعى ماء يا
غنماتي ماء ماء ما احلاكي ما ما ما اطعمكم
ماء ما ما اسقي ماء ما عشبا اعطيكم وغذاء
ان شئتم اسقي ماء ماء ماء ماء ماء ماء ماء
ماء ماء ماء ما ما ما ما ما ما
ما
ه